pretend so um what made me think of this
topic is I went to Carnival recently now
that was an interesting experience
experience I've never been to a festival
so it was a lot to take in he went in
blind I did not know what I was signing
up for
um a lot of ass
a lot of yeah there's a lot of
everything a lot of everything anyways
so I went around and asked people to
rank themselves one to ten and the most
common answer I got from women was I'm a
10 I'm a 10 I'm a 10. and to me like a
10 is that you're perfect
which to me is a little bit narcissistic
so why why are people so quick to say
that they're a 10. oh
I mean you have to kind of
think that like people will always be
drawn to confidence you can't just go
around saying I mean
um I mean even if you are like
subjectively gay
I don't know five six maybe
um you can't you can't let everyone know
that you have to be like no listen I'm a
10. you don't think it's delusion I
think confidence is sexy so even if you
aren't like objectively or
conventionally attractive someone that
is very Charming is still seen as
attractive or just Charming in general
but it's not like true confidence when
it's just arrogance
I don't think it's arrogance because I
don't think having confidence makes you
arrogant but it's like why are they
confident so if they know that they're
not they don't really feel that they're
attend but they're just saying that
they're a 10. it's a good point I guess
it's more than like attractiveness as in
how you look it's almost like I feel
confident myself you cannot be like you
might have like
pimples or like scars on your face but
if you're a confident person you can
still be a 10 no
wouldn't you say that means you have no
room to improve
I think I understand what you mean but I
feel like
um I don't really like this idea of like
humans having to constantly improve
themselves because it means that we're
in a Perpetual state of not enough I
feel like it's kind of good that some
people have accepted like oh I'm just
good as I am because then you know it's
a happy state to be in yeah you could be
good as you are as a five
it's not an insult that's average you
know yeah there'll always be someone
that will uh like you yeah there's
someone for everyone definitely
there's more there's more women on the
planet than men
yeah so like by the Numbers there's not
some people get left behind you know
what I mean that's just like that stuff
out here
um
so
um I have a clip for us to react to
where we kind of dived into this a
little bit blessing pull up the first
clip I I kept my original stance yeah
this one so this was you can see how far
the shows come because this was an old
show but it started from the beginning
blessing
yeah I started from the I don't know why
it started there yeah
foreign
so do you do you think you're perfect
no I think there's Beauty in
imperfection you know Perfection is not
uh why are you talking over me
Beauty and there's a difference anywhere
Jessica I believe that I'm an 11 out of
10 just because
I was not done talking
um I genuinely believe that Perfection
is not real but there's Beauty and
imperfection and I think no like you're
you're very attractive like I think
you're like I think you're attractive
but I don't know but wait wait wait can
you let me finish so what I'm saying
like like to me I would never say I'm a
10 because like a 10 is like perfect and
I don't think I'm perfect so I get like
is that but we were saying looks wise
right yeah and I genuinely see myself as
genuinely beautiful I genuinely see
myself as someone who is a goddess
because at the end of the day
Society is what decides on beauty
standards right right and I can I don't
have to follow that beauty standard
right I genuinely believe that I'm
beautiful yeah well and I'm not taking
that away from you I just like I just
could I just couldn't I just could never
say like I wouldn't say you're perfect
you know what I mean yeah yeah and
that's and that's what I'm not saying
I'm just playing around yeah I think I'm
really a 10 out of 10. like genuinely I
feel like I'm a 10 out of 10. yeah I
take care of myself what has given you
that uh my looks we were only talking
about look we were talking about
personality or skill or anything like
that is is that based on the way people
have treated you throughout your life no
this is based on how I was raised and
how I view myself and how I've worked
hard to see the beauty that I deserve to
see so I worked so you see an 11 out of
10 Beauty I wouldn't bro it's a joke
okay okay
yeah like I just said I consider myself
a 10 out of 10 for sure so you think
you're up there with so who would you
see in like the media that's like a 10
out of 10. why are we going based off of
media people no like why does that
matter well because because on society
well because that like society's Beauty
Supply I don't give a [ __ ] about Society
that's the key here is that I I have my
own Viewpoint right like okay so who
would you class as a 10 out of 10. what
apart from yourself well because like in
order in order to scale someone one to
ten someone has to not be a ten right so
so I fully agree with that yeah and so
but I'm not mine but we asked what I
think I am what she thinks he is what
you think you are I'm not going based
off of anybody else except for what I
see in the mirror right so but then like
that almost wouldn't be a scale that
like because then you have no way to
measure [ __ ] right okay so it's like
your way of rebelling against the scale
almost forget Rebellion it's just
genuinely how I feel like and I'm not
saying like I like again like I think I
think you're beautiful like yeah
for you to say that you're a five out of
time right but I just think I live like
I'm not making a comparison in her own
right she is
yes but like you're in her own room but
I just think if I was if I was a 10 I
would have had modeling yeah
sorry we talk about problems
but do you know what I'm saying like I
think if I was like a 10 right then I
would have had model it I would have had
modeling contracts by now I would have
had people I would have had results to
show that I'm I would have had NFL NBA
players but remember that is all based
on beauty standards that are set by
that's based on reality I do like that's
society that's reality and like but I
don't see the same way that other people
do that yeah let me ask the question do
you think there's an objective Beauty
standard yes
can you describe objective to me as in
like what the Baseline okay something
like an objective Society Beauty
standard so for example art is that good
art or is all art the same
I feel like that's kind of different
because art art is also something that's
all about perspective subjective yeah
it's objective yeah to do it but in in
in in if you look at Medieval buildings
especially Americans notice this when
they come here they love our Asian
architecture right compared to their
architecture there is a standard that's
and like a stick figure versus like
Picasso
I guess um when it comes to that you
know art is something that you put time
and skill and detail into I can't really
say the same for people no because my
point is that as as genuinely human
beings can identify what's Beauty and
what's not
okay so what is your reaction to this
clip
what he was saying about
um you know we have ideas about what's
beautiful or not I do I do think
I'm pretty sure like your brain is
kind of programmed to recognize certain
things as more aesthetically pleasing
enough even though subjective it's I'm
pretty sure there's even like certain
measurements of a specific type of face
that humans are more um
find more symmetry yeah like that yeah
there's been things like studies about
women with like neotenic faces like baby
faces that men tend to find more
attractive and babies like stairs stare
at for longer so I do feel like
there is an objective um scared of
attractiveness that you can judge people
on obviously it's not like
cross-cultural like maybe
in the East it's different but I feel
like in the west you can definitely say
a person you could write a person on a
scale based on what collectively in the
west people think and you could like
write that on one to ten do you believe
their beauty is in the eye of the holder
the eye of the beholder
I guess so because someone in East Asia
might not find
um someone in the west attractive
um so it really depends on that person
like what they grew up with like what
they grew up was it um what they their
society grew up with that's attractive
would affect how they would perceive a
person so there's like pictures of
people that you might not find
attractive in like medieval times but
back then people would like kill
themselves or done crazy things just to
be with this person but like now we're
looking like oh I don't see the
attraction there so I definitely feel
like it's definitely a subjective
experience what do you think yeah no I
definitely feel that way as one I also
think
um
your taste changes as you get older what
you might find attractive and what
you're drawn to initially initially when
you're younger or ultimately change as
you get older
um you might go for like the
the obvious pick but then as you get
older you might start thinking certain
different things or more beautiful do
you think that's for a manner for women
oh because because that sounds like a
woman's point of view not necessarily a
man's like I think I think when we get
older we're like well we don't
necessarily need these things but man I
I it seems like they just like hot likes
me yeah they're more uh visually
motivated than us yeah I feel like
they're more Primal than like women like
I don't know she hot in there yeah but
it's kind of cute because like some
women are like oh like I want my man to
have a nice job to be so intelligent but
I go like oh I think you're cute and
that's kind of enough listen what do you
think is Beauty in the eye of the
beholder
um
I
yes in the term in in the um
when we're thinking about character so I
think personally for me I I rate myself
for four
not physically really what yeah I'm
definitely not four no no no no yeah
but I generally like it doesn't bother
me I'm just I'm very objective about it
I I rate myself for four however I
honestly believe what we're missing
today is like uh everybody's saying that
what it appears to be everybody saying
oh I'm a 10 I'm a 10 but they
misconstrued it in terms of their
personality everything as a package
there are ten so there is no room for
improvement and um
I mean I'm thinking about like at what
point does humility come in uh you know
it seems like non-existent therefore
they won't really do any you know
introspection and are they self-aware
and all that stuff so I'm just saying
just saying you're a 10 it's just it's
problematic but from what I'm saying is
that um so I think I'm a four but with
my personality and everything and all my
character all these very important
things they kind of make the package
they make the person and these are the
ways that people fall in love
um you know with somebody's character so
I think that's what they're
fundamentally missing when they just say
there are 10. okay so you're a 10 but
what about your personality I'm a 10
there as well I'm just perfect all
around
which just comes across as arrogance to
me
what do you guys think of the body
positivity movement
in terms of what do you think it's good
for society
no
it isn't why well uh who who's whose
body are we saying that it's that that
they're fine
like what what change has have we seen
because no I'm just I just wanted to
know how you think uh well for example
like I think about a while ago I saw a
clearly obese woman uh on the cover of a
magazine I can't remember what magazine
it was but then they said very clearly
this is healthy and I'm just like are
they trying to manipulate me into
thinking that that's healthy and she was
in sportswear but clearly she's not it's
like clearly you ain't going to the gym
I know right and she's been on the
treadmill in a minute like come on but
but what I find generally heartbreaking
is that okay yes I'm I'm physically Slim
Right so people are gonna be like oh
you're just like fat shaming but I
genuinely have concerns for her so when
I see people who are like oh yeah girl
you're a 10 sorry I can't speak like
that I'm terrible but yeah yeah you know
yes Queen and I'm like I'm it breaks my
heart I'm just like you don't care about
her you're not telling her you're not
encouraging her to change you know
there's a risk of diabetes are they
saying um diabetes is a 10 are they
saying asthma is a 10 I think depression
is a 10. uh so yeah you could say yeah
you're a 10 but no one's there when
she's crying all alone and she has all
these health problems what happens to
all their energy then and it is really
heartbreaking as soon and what
and I've seen plenty of people who have
been obese and they've you know they've
made tick tocks and stuff and they say
um on The Tick Tock uh I've done this to
myself or I'm going to take
responsibility and then you see their
progression and there's so much happier
and they're not in that delusion and
somebody who genuinely cares about you
will tell you the ugly truth but they
are telling you they're not telling you
a beautiful lie and that's what you want
from a friend and that's what we should
have in society if we have everybody's
like oh yeah you're fine yeah you're
fine yeah you're fine
um it's actually really unfair and I'm
just thinking like in a way I think it's
really Sinister because if I was fat and
my friend told me you're fine I'm like
she doesn't give a [ __ ] about me as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible